la force de frappe ukrainienne a-t-elle
changé de dimension engagée dans une
contre-offensive contre la Russie depuis
début juin l'Ukraine multiplie les
tentatives de frappes sur le territoire
adverse dans la nuit de dimanche à lundi
un drone ukrainien ainsi frappé un
commissariat de police dans la région de
brillante c'est le gouverneur régional
Alexandre bogomas qui l'a annoncé
précisant coûterait les dégâts matériels
l'attaque n'avait fait aucune victime
dimanche d'autres drones avaient frappé
un centre d'affaires de Moscou le maire
de la ville Sergueï sobiannine faisait
état de 25 appareils ces autres avaient
été repoussés détruit par la défense
anti-aérienne russe en Crimée ces drones
sont devenus un outil indispensable pour
l'Ukraine comme l'expliquait Le Figaro
la semaine dernière en immersion avec un
groupe chargé de ces frappes l'un de ses
membres expliquait le drone change le
théâtre de la guerre il permet l'avancée
de l'infanterie car il frappe les
arrières logistiques ou d'artillerie de
l'ennemi et reconnaît la première ligne
auparavant ils permettent notamment aux
Ukrainiens de viser le territoire russe
et même